hi today I'm gonna talk about Cloud run
health checks a new feature that just
launched in preview you will learn what
they are and why they're useful
first let's look at the life cycle of a
container there's the startup phase when
your container is getting ready to serve
requests and the serving phase when it
actually serves requests
so when does a container transition from
starting to serving
today Cloud run uses a TCP startup probe
as soon as your container listens on its
TCP Port it starts to serve requests
with Cloud run health checks you can set
an HTTP probe and this is useful for
apps that start listening on a DSP Port
before they are ready to serve requests
you can also set a new kind of probe a
liveness probe a liveness probe
determines if a container is still able
to serve requests and if it's not it
will be shut down and Cloud run starts a
new container
you can use liveness probes to stop
containers that get into a corrupt local
state or to force a restart after a
certain amount of time
thank you for listening if you want to
learn more check out my recent talk at
Cloud next in Munich and even if you
don't like containers there are a few
solid dad jokes in there so what do I
say when there's a duck flying into you
check out the dog